nintendo sure loves irony when I hear
the word new I think of something I
haven't seen before the Nintendo well
Nintendo just dust off something from
their archive and slaps a new on it I've
already argued that modern Nintendo
isn't that interested in innovation so
instead of beating that poor horse I'll
show you why the recycled elements in
Yoshi's new island are what make it
unique just take a look at the health
system whether you love the sound of
Mario crying would rather Jam a spatula
in your ear you have to admit the
Nintendo's approach is pretty out there
yoshi is nearly indestructible but baby
mario is as fragile as a baby riding a
dinosaur can be having to chase down a
bubble encased babies pretty different
from getting killed by just taking a
couple hits right and then there's a
level design stages sprawl like a
colorful labyrinth and you can't be sure
which walls are solid and which hide
secrets without touching them most games
empower your peepers but in Yoshi's new
island your eyes only tell you lies or
show you lies either way your eyes are
lying also yo she's kind of a vehicle in
his own right every rideable animal is
but in Yoshi's new island he takes that
whole vehicle thing one step further by
transforming into some horrible dinosaur
machine hybrid oyoshi of course Mario
punches you in the head when I want you
to eat you're nothing more than a
soulless helicopter even your movement
is uniquely Yoshi that poor dinosaur
plod slowly along and can barely jump
but he can somehow hover even without
the benefit of wings so jumping isn't
all that important Yoshi's new island
it's all about finding secret ways to
reach new heights like lobbing an A get
a cloud so there's not much new going on
in Yoshi's new island when we have
learned a valuable lesson if you're
going to rip off another game aim your
sights at saying that's really different
from any other game out there that way
everyone's a winner